parce que personnellement moi je suis
venu pour m'amuser pour dans une
cérémonie que je regarde depuis tout
petit et qui est pour moi culte
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'on va passer
une super soirée et on peut passer
passer à côté de miss france on a tous
regardé miss france et ont de toute
manière et encore plus ceux qui disent
qu'ils regardent pas on regarde tous
miss france parce que c'est un super
spectacle est une super belle émission
de divertissement
maintenant pour la jeune fille qui va
être élu j'attends que ce soit une une
magnifique représentante de d'aider des
femmes et de la femme française dans
toute son élégance mais aussi ça que ça
soit une jeune fille brillante avec de
l'esprit en tout cas et et gfic et de
l'humour aussi parce que c'est bien et
puis qu'ils aient toutes ces qualités là
ouais c'est difficile c'est difficile
parce que de réunir toutes ces qualités
là les est engagée bien sûr engagé va je
pense que c'est ce qu'on leur demande
aussi dans l'année ils ont pas mal
d'événements aussi d'être engagée parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est difficile de ne pas
l'être dans le monde dans lequel on vit
bien mais qu'ils engagent est en tout
cas concernés par par par tout ce que
l'on peut vivre aujourd'hui qu'ils
soient au courant de tout ce qui se
passe et en france et ailleurs dans le
monde aussi absolument je suis venu à
plusieurs reprises et je trouve que
c'est assez fabuleux que la ville de
châteauroux accueil miss france cette
année c'est un peu inattendu justement
et c'est ça que je trouve bien
apparemment je sais pas comment ça c'est
ça c'est organiser toute cette affaire
parce que je sais qu apparemment c'était
la miss miss guyane l'année précédente
donc je pense que c'est là la ville de
châteauroux qui a dû demander ce que
l'élection se se passe ici et je trouve
que c'est une bonne chose justement ça
change un peu de de toutes les grandes
villes et de tous les grands et need un
peu partout de se retrouver justement
plein coeur de la france qu'est ce que
j'aime bah écoutez je vais vous dire ce
soir le public certainement qu'on va
retrouver ce soir et je pense que le
public est
extrêmement investi est ici est venu en
masse ce soir et puis et puis voilà
j'attends j'ai plein de surprises qu'est
ce qui est précieux pour moi dans la vie
la famille la famille et les siens voilà
les miens les miens c'est ce qu'elle a
de plus précieux certainement mais pour
moi merci à vous